shoot the new spider-man far from home
trailer Oh just for you guys exclusively
Sam Jackson trailer yeah I was so cool
even though I got goosebumps I was like
JT the main focus is for him to not be
spider-man per se but he gets dragged
into it but you know he reluctantly
saves the world again with Mysterio oh
yeah
mr. poster was a good guy in this
they're both teaming up to kill it kill
the game to defeat all these elemental
monsters there are these threats to the
worlds the elementals elemental
creatures and their and mysterious um
you know who who knows about them and
wants to make sure that the world is
safe from them and and Nick Fury asked
him to come on and help because he's the
only one who really sort of understands
them in a way and and then you know he
teams up with friendly neighborhood
spider-man and unfortunately has to make
him become more than just a friendly
neighborhood spider-man cool
black and gray suit we call the stealth
suit but I call it the comfy suit it's a
suit designed by Nick Fury in order to
do something that I'm not gonna tell you
because it's a secret okay but it's
really cool it has all sorts of cool
little features and for me as an actor
it was really interesting to try and
figure out how spider-man would move and
act in such different attire know his
commitment his energy is non-stop right
and I can feel him when he comes out
there cuz he wants to tell all of you
everything about the movie and he knows
that he can so it's mostly just us being
like oh you know and for me I know there
are a lot of movies but this character
Mysterio when they showed it to me was
so original and the idea and and who he
is and why he's there is so original and
so special that for me I was like man
they they did it again you know I didn't
think they could and they do and they do
it every time cool cool lights up it
lights up like sometimes the lights
don't always work light up the right way
they go disco colors there actually was
one day where they all just started
going different colors and I can't see
in that I can't see the lights
so you can see with and everyone would
start looking at me like it's really
cool I mean the coolest thing about the
suit is that there are some major
secrets in it yeah totally pretty cool
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my breakdown of the spider-man far
from home Comic Con panel and the
trailer that they showed Sony and Marvel
aren't allowing any of the footage to be
posted online so I had to make this in a
roundabout way
like they say during that interview they
gave away a whole bunch of really big
details that make the film sound bigger
and way weirder than I ever possibly
imagined and quite a bit different from
the comics so I just broke this down
top-10 style there's a new brand of that
IMAX ticket giveaway going on - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from
their comic-con panel on the video so
starting with number 10 the trailer
itself didn't acknowledge anything from
infinity war or Avengers endgame it
doesn't place itself in the timeline at
all if you're like the one person on the
planet that did not see infinity war you
saw spider-man homecoming and then you
watch this footage you wouldn't be able
to tell that anything crazy had happened
so that's just a step around spoilers
they obviously don't want to give away
anything from the end of Avengers 4 I
would expect them to continue that theme
with all the future trailers that they
drop because this isn't coming out till
July well after Avengers 4 9 you start
out with the Mysterio reveal you see him
in the suit obviously Jake Gyllenhaal
was talking about the suit itself having
a lot of secrets but the twist in how
it's created where it comes from and
what his character is all about is very
different from the comics so number
eight one of the biggest surprises is
that the villains of the movie at least
at the beginning of the movie are touted
as these elemental monsters there are
elemental characters in Marvel Comics
history but they're super deep cut from
the Doctor Strange comics so obviously
spider-man has crossed over with Doctor
Strange in the comics before but here's
the thing about that I think that
there's all a big trick that Mysterio is
pulling because of the abilities that he
has in the comics he's the master of
illusion so just keep that in the back
of your mind
7 really big change this is actually a
pretty big deal Mysterio starts out as a
hero through most of the film as the
actors describe him unless they're being
blatantly misleading he's one of the
only people that understands the threat
of these elemental creatures so
Nick Fury is the one that tasks him with
joining shield because one of Nick
Fury's primary jobs is also to protect
the earth the same way that Doctor
Strange does but on a more non mystical
level then number six obviously because
he's a villain in the comics and they're
starting out with a very strange story
they might be trying to Winter Soldier
him because Jake Gyllenhaal also said at
this big Comic Con panel that the core
of the movie is his relationship with
spider-man so they start out buddy-buddy
think about what might happen later in
the film to cause a falling out and what
might turn Mysterio to the dark side of
the force so that he becomes a villain
in future movies like if you're Mysterio
and you're not totally all there up top
but you have great skills think about it
this way Mysterio has faked other
villains to make himself look like a
hero when he takes them down so what if
these special elemental creatures that
only he understands are his own
creations and that's why he's the only
person that understands them and
eventually spider-man finds out about
that and has to take him down like you
would any other villain so just imagine
the mental gymnastics going on in
Mysterio's head that he feels like he
has a relationship with Peter Parker and
he's trying to be a hero we don't know
exactly how crazy he is because the way
they write all these Marvel villains has
been getting better and better like kill
monger is just the latest example in an
evolution of a style of Marvel villain
so if Mysterio is trying to Gaslight
Nick Fury in gaslights spider-man into
thinking that he's a hero because he's
helping take down these crazy giant
creatures but then winds up being the
person to have created them it is gonna
be spectacular so even though the way
they talked about the movie it sounds
very different from the comments in
reality they're using a very classic
Mysterio comic-book twist faking things
to make people think that you're better
than you actually are but even though we
don't know how they're gonna end the
movie or what the future of Mysterio is
in the MCU because Jake Gyllenhaal is
such a big get and he has such great
energy with Tom Holland and the other
actors on screen I think they're gonna
try and keep him around for as long as
possible number 5 one of the other first
scenes that we saw in the trailer was a
Peter in his spider-man costume hugging
Aunt May then going on his European
vacation with his class it's most of the
characters from his debate team like
we've seen in all the behind the scenes
Martin stars mr. Harrington is one of
the chaperones taking them all over
place I mean it's a European trip but
they're also learning as they go it's
meant to be a vacation like he's trying
to not be spider-man but then number
four as jake gyllenhaal said Mysterio
working with Nick Fury to take down the
threat of these elemental creatures
ropes spider-man in a very reluctant
Peter Parker so he has to go back on the
clock again as a superhero with some
special upgrades for Nick Fury
so three they're officially calling the
new spider-man noir looking suit the
stealth suit Tom Holland joked about it
a little bit they did not say what the
name of the brand-new upgraded stark
tech suit is going to be with the red
and black the funny thing about Tom
Holland though is that he says that they
make that special stealth suit for a
reason that he can't tell us special
function but it's called a stealth suit
the reason why you would wear it is so
that you would go undetected by the
villains I think when he was talking
about that he was just talking about the
larger plot line that he gets involved
in while he's wearing that suit but
we've seen a lot of behind the scenes
with him and Mysterio in that fight on
the big carousel and - there was a whole
bunch of Nick Fury like they said Tom
Holland got goosebumps because he's
being a badass like Nick Fury normally
is remember all the crazy stuff he did
during Winter Soldier especially that
opening scene with a car he gets to do
stuff like that during the movie but a
lot of his functions are mostly support
functions helping spider-man in helping
Mysterio that was a really funny scene
with Nick Fury bust into their hotel
room while they were getting ready to
sleep and darts
Ned leads in the neck so that he passes
out so he can talk to Peter Parker and
he sits down and says so I finally get
to meet the spider-man like he's trying
to make fun of him a little bit the same
way that he used to make fun of Iron Man
like Iron Man thought of himself as a
pretty important person Peter Parker
kind of thinks of himself as a big deal
because he's an Avenger now so they're
just continuing that funny dynamic and
then there are a couple scenes of Peters
developing romance with Michelle
throughout that European vacation that
just develops through the film and then
number one the only real big climactic
footage that they had in it was of
Mysterio in a big battle in his suit and
even though he didn't say too many
things about it yes there is a version
of a fishbowl there was no mention of
Ironman like I said no big spoilers for
Avengers 4 or anything like that but the
way they talk about it makes it feel
like this film is more connected to the
larger MCU than ever so if you were
worried about spider-man's future in the
MCU after this hopefully that makes you
feel a little better because they do
have to Rin
they're sharing arrangement after this
movie premieres before they make that
third spider-man film but big question
for you guys let me know in the comments
what do you think about them starting
out with Mysterio being a hero in the
MCU in his slow potential descent to
sinister six villain they didn't say
exactly when they're gonna drop all this
footage online but it sounds like it's
either gonna be next week or the week
after that before the end of the year if
I hear any big details about that I'll
be sure to include it in a future Marvel
video but I'll be doing some new
Avengers for tomorrow so leave all your
requests in the comments while you wait
for everything click here to re-watch
the Avengers 4 trailer a billion more
times and click here to rewatch the
Captain Marvel trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]